[موسيقى]
ان اتمنى بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
هجومه يعكس تفوق اوكرانيا في الحرب
الالكترونيه ويفضح اخطاء روسيا المتكرره
والفادحه
قلق في تل ابيب من توتر العلاقه مع واشنطن
واسرائيل تجهز قدراتها لتحرك مستقل ضد اي
سيناري نووي ايراني
بعد القمع الرقمي ايران على راس الدولي
التي تشهد تطبيقات وقيودا خبيثه لتشويش
وحجب الانترنت والتجسس
وصفه ركود يهدد العالم وسياسات تقشف قاسيه
في بريطانيا اسعار الغاز تنقذ اوروبا من
ازمه طاقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه انها انعطافه
خطيره في مسار الحرب وتصعيد من العيار
الثقيل شهدته العمليه القتاليه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا فبعد ساعات من هجمات الروسيه
المكثفه استهدفت كياب على مدى يومين
متتاليين جاء الرد من اوكرانيا بهدمه
اسفرت عن اعلى حصيله قتلى من الجنود الروس
في ضربه واحده الحرب هي سابقه في العدد
والتصريح ايضا
روسيا اعلنت عن حصيله قتل الهدوم وعددهم
ثمانيه وسبعون جنديا الهجوم الاوكرانيه
للقوات الروسيه في منطقه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا واعلنت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه مسؤوليتها عنها الهجوم واثاره
قلقا وتسالا كيف سيكون الرد الروسي على ما
وصف بانها
اثرته مكيفا
وفي تفاصيل هجوم مكيفك هذا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه تم
تنفيذه بصواريخ هاي مارس شديده الانفجار
وان دفاعات الجويه اسقطت اثنين منها كما
قال مصدر الموارد لروسيا في دونيتك ان
هجوم ماكيكا تم بعد السماح للمجندين
الروسي الجدد في معسكر التدريب باستخدام
هواتفهم واشار المصدر الى ان الجيش
الاوكراني حدد احداثيات مواقع المجندين
الروس فيما كيرك بعد استخدامهم لهواتفهم
اكتب
امريكيه الصنع مركزه تجمع الوحدات القوات
المسلحه الروسيه قرب مستوطنه في جمهوريه
المسك الشعبيه اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه صاروخين من نوعه مارس ونتيجه
لتدمير مركز التجمع باربعه الصواريخ براس
حربي شديد انفجار قتل 63 جنديا روسيا
وسيتم تقديم كل المساعده
لاقارب واصدقاء الجنود الذين سقطوا
للمزيد معنا من دنيتك مراسل للعربيه رائد
الاغبر مرحبا بك معنا رائد المزيد من
التفاصيل حول هذه العمليه في مكيفكا رائد
انت معي
المعارك اصبحت شرسه جدا ومستعره على
الجبهات ومن خلال القسم راجمات الصواريخ
والمدفعيه وصلت لايدي الجيش الاوكراني
مدفعيات وراجمات صواريخ تشيكيه وبولنديه
حديثه يعني تطلق صواريخ المدارس الى اكثر
من 40 سنه كيلو مترا تحمل رؤوس خارقه
تخترق الجدران وتخترق هل تسمعني صهيب نعم
نعم انت الهواء تفضل
يعني تطلق صواريخ خارقه يعني تختلف جدران
والدروع همم يعني عدا عن سابقاتها من
الصواريخ والقذائف والسوفيتيه التي كانت
يعني تنطر الشضايا ويعني همم تقتل من يكون
حولنا ايضا صواريخ هذه مجلس الامريكيه حيث
القصف الذي اسلفت بالتحدث عنه قالت الدفاع
الروسيه بانها 63 قتيلا لكن المرصد المحلي
هنا في دانيت اشاره الى ارتفاع حصيله همم
قتل بينما قالوا بان هناك 136 جنديا في
المشفى كما انه هناك اعداد كبيره تحت
الانقاض هناك ايضا عبر تسريبات عن ان مبنى
[__] اقل من 300 ايه يعني شخص ما بين جندي
ومقادر قال ايضا مسؤول في احدى
الفرق الروسيه لان احدى المقاطعات بانه
ارسل جنودا الى هذه همم النقطه للتعبئه
المركزيه في الفعل هنا ايضا الدفاع
الروسيه اسمح لي صهيب هنا الدفاع الروسيه
والسلطات المحليه قالت بانها ترد على هذا
الهجوم وتنحي المئات من المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين بقصف عنيف ربما لا تسمع اصوات
القصف لكن بالفعل خلفي هنا خلف هذه
النافذه يعني احيانا الاضاءات والاصوات
الصارخه التي نسمعها بيتنا لا نميز ما بين
القصف وسقوط القذائف والصواريخ الوضع خطير
جدا لم يسبقه
رائد همم يعني انت تؤكد الان ان الرد
الروسي على استهداف المجندين في مكيف قد
بدا بالفعل يعني
بالفعل بدا الرد منذ عموما لابد من
الاشاره الى ان هذه الحادثه او هذه
الواقعه كانت في ليله راس السنه لكن تم
الاعلان عنها اليوم كان هناك يعني تعتيم
على الاضرار التي لحقت بجنود في الجيش
الروسي كما ان الموقف حتى الان ذهبنا
للتحري هناك يعني لم يسمح لنا الامن
بالدخول او الاقتراب من المنطقه حتى ااه
يعني بالفعل ما زال هنا تعطيل كبير على
هذه الضربه لكن الدفاع الروسيه وسلطات
المحليه العسكريه هناك تؤكد بانها ردت
وبعنف ونحت مئات المقاتلين ودمرت مئات
الاليات عفوارات الاليات عند
الطرقرانيسك شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
معنى منه موسكو المحلل العسكريه الروسيه
سرجيه شاشكوف سيد شاشكوف اهلنا بكم معنا
منذ متى كانت روسيا تعترف بسقوط ضحايا
بهذا العدد في الحرب في اوكرانيا
والسلام عليكم والسلام على مين اتبع الهدى
الضربه المؤسفه والدماويه التي وقعت في
منتصف الليل من 31 ديسمبر لواحد يناير
كانت ضربه مؤلمه وهي اثار
بين المجتمع الروسي بشكل واسع وخصوصا في
مواقع الاجتماع
الاتصال
[موسيقى]
عندما اعترفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بسقوط همم
قتيل بين صفوف همم
المقاتلين الروس وهذا المعنى رسمي همم
صباح هذا اليوم همم
اعتقد ان همم
العدد الحقيقي
نعم
بنفس الوقت
يجب الاعتراف بان العدد الذي تم اعلانها
من قبل الاعلام الاوكراني قالوا انه هناك
300 كتيره 400 كثير ايضا هذا بعيد كل
البعد
جنودها في هذه الحرب
في ربما لم نتعود على ان تعترف روسيا
بخسائرها في هذه الحرب هناك من يربط هذا
باستعداد روسيا للرد بشكل قاسم على مقتل
هذا العدد من جنودها
الفرق الوحيد بين اعتراف روسيا رسميا
بسقوط هذا العدد من المقتلين بين القتل
والجارحه
وعفن تصرفاتها تصرفات اجهزه الاعلام
الروسيه سابقا هو مجرد وقت ايه
عامل الوقت انه سابقا
الاعترافات مثل هذه كانت تتاخر على الحادث
همم كم يوم احو حتى كم اسبوع همم الان
الاعلام الرسمي هذا بعد كم ساعه من وقوع
الحاليه وهناك سؤال يتحدث نفسه نفسه همم
وخصوصا في مواقع الاتصال الاجتماعي الروسي
همم هل همم سوف ياتي انتقام انتقام همم
هذه الضربه المؤلمه والدرباويه والقويه
الموضوع اوسع من الانتقام الموضوع
[موسيقى]
انتقام يعني فوتشي يخص على كارت شخصيه
عيديه او علاقات بين
مستوى ادنى بكثير مين الحرب التي هي وارده
حاليا في اوكراني وخصوصا معنا اخذ بحريره
ان هي الحرب ليست بين روسي
ولكن هي الحرب
اوسع مجالا طيب قبل ان يدركنا الوقت ارجو
ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا لاننا نريد ان
نتوقف مع الخطا الذي ارتكب همم اذا في هذا
الاستهداف الاوكراني والذي اطاح بعشرات
الجنود الروس الخطا هو انه استخدم هواتفهم
المحموله في ثقنه عسكريه حساسه فكانت تلك
الغلطه صيدا للقوات الاوكرانيه فكلفت
الجيش الروسي العشرات من القتل والجرحى
بين جنوده فيما تقول كيف ان العدد عاف ما
اعلن عنه وتفوق هذا هذا تفوق تسجله
اوكرانيا في الجانب الالكتروني من حربها
ضد باروك نتابع التقدير
ضربه اوكرانيه دقيقه وموجعه ودميه قتلى
وجرحى من الجنود الروس
موسكو اقرت بمقتل 63 جنديا لكن كيف تقول
ان العدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير
الهجوم وقع في شرق اوكرانيا تحديدا بمدينه
مكيفك شرقي دونيتسك التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا
اربعه صواريخ مارس ضربت مركزا انتشار مؤقت
للجيش الروسي في المدينه العمليه العسكريه
نفذت بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه دقيقه
تقول مصادر مواليه في دونتس ان استخدام
المجندين الروس الواصلين للتو الى المعسكر
لهاتفهم المحموله بكثافه سمح للجيش
الاوكراني بتحديد موقعهم الجغرافي خطا
روسي فادح وقاتل سبق ان تكرر في حرب
اوكرانيا فالقوات تعتمد بشكل متكرر على
اجهزه اتصالات وخطوط غير امنه او مؤمنه
كالهواتف المحموله واجهزه الراديو التي
تعمل بنظام الضغط للتحدث الهجوم الاخير
يعكس قدرا كبيرا من التقدم الاوكراني في
الحرب الالكترونيه بفضل بكياف بمعدات
غربيه متطوره
بحسب خبراء فان اوكرانيا يستفادت من
الاتصالات الروسيه نفسها وحجزت اشارتها
واعمت رقابتها واستولت على بعض انظمه
الحرب الالكترونيه الاكثر تقدمها لكن ثم
من يرى ان القاده الروس العسكريين اخطاوا
حين افترضوا ان الجيش الاوكراني لم يتطور
كثيرا منذ عام 2015
كما اخطاوا حين تجاهلوا تاثير المعدات
الغربيه وتدريب النيكل الوحدات الاوكرانيه
غير ان القيود الروسيه وهراميتها العسكريه
جديده المركزيه اسهمت في ابطال قواتها
باتخاذ قرارات ميدانيه سريعه ومستقله امر
حولها الى اهداف سهله امام وحدات اوكرانيه
اكثر استقلاليه وان كانت اقل عددا وعتادا
في موسكو ما مدى فداحه هذا الخطا السماح
للمجندين بفتحي هواتفهم المحموله وبالتالي
جرى تحديد اماكنهم بسهوله من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني
بان
الدقه
الفضيع لتوجيه هذه الدربه على مكان تواجد
المجندين الروس في مدينه مكيف كافيه
جمهوريه
الروسيه همم كان ينتج عن فتح
الموبايلات
والهدافيات الدقيقه الى مواقع
فتح النيران لمنظمات صاروخيه
الامريكيه الصناعه التي يتم اطلاقها
وتوجيهها
باهدافيات دقيقه وبيستخدام نظام همم
ولذلك همم هناك سؤال همم لماذا همم
منظومه الدفاع
الجوي الروسيه لم تسقط تلك الاقمار
الاصطناعيه الامريكيه التي تزود الجيش
اللبناني بهدفيات الدقيقه
للجنود
والمعدات العسكريه الروسيه بتلك الدقه
علما بان الولايات المتحده هي مطورده
يعني هذه الكلمه في هذه اللعبه عليها
العسكريه لان التزويد الجيش لطرف الاخر
بالمعلومات الاستخباراتيه
والتزويده
باحداثيات التلف الاخر
وتجهيزه بالاسلحه الحديثه وتدريب الكادر
المحلي على استخدامه هذا هو
كله يدور على ان امريكا
المساله ليست ضربه اوكرانيه فقط بل هي
نتيجه هذا الدعم الغربي الدعم الامريكي
بالتحديد هل الرد الروسي سيكون اوسع نطاقا
من اوكرانيا ربما
وزير الدفاع نعم
من واقع خبراتك العسكريه
كتحليل العسكريه
مباشر بين روسيا المتحده لاجنا الدوله
[موسيقى]
همم
يدركون بشكل كامل ان الاسلام والمباشر بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده سوف يؤدي الى
نهايه الحضاره الانسانيه
بشكل كامل لذلك الرئيس الامريكي يكرر
تكراره بسبب ان امريكا لا تاسع الى الشباب
لا يمكن استبدادام الاسلحه النوويه الا في
حاله ظهور
الهكر المباشر المؤدي الى همم
نهايه شكرا جزيلا لكم المحلل العسكري
والروسي ياسر جاي شاشكوف كنتم معنا مباشره
من موسكو
[موسيقى]
ومع كل هذا التصعيد منعرج اخر ينتظر الحرب
الاوكرانيه فالكثير من التصريحات
والتلميحات تشير الى نوايا روسيا شن هجوم
جديد على اوكرانيا هذه المره اخر من اشاره
الى ذلك الامين العام
لحزنيتمبر الذي قال ان هناك دلاله تشير
الى ان موسكو تستعد للهجوم البريه على
اوكرانيا وقبله كان مستشار الرئيس
الاوكرانيات قد اكد ايضا ان روسيا تدرب
جنودا استعدادا لهجوم جديد المحتمل مصدر
تحدث عن الهجمه الروسيه الجديده وهو معهد
الدراسات الحرب في واشنطن وذلك في تقرير
نشره مؤخرا
السؤال المطروح الان وبعد حوالي سنه من
بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه كيف تكون
هذه العمليه البريه الجديده في حال حدوثها
حسب التقارير فان الهجوم المحتمل سيبدا من
بيلاروسيا سيما هو ان موسكو حشدت قواتها
بشكل واضح مؤخرا حشد قوه الروسيه في
بيلاروسيا يعطي فكره حول المصاري المحتمل
للعمليه البريه التي قد تنطلق من شمال
اوكرانيا وربما ستستهدف العاصمه والهدف من
استهداف الشمال الاوكراني قد يكون مجرد
تكتيك للتضليل لجذب القوات الاوكرانيه
بعيدا عن المناطق الرئيسيه نقطه الانطلاق
الثانيه المحتمله للهجوم البريه الروسي قد
تكون من شمال غربي حيث تم رصد زياده في
اعداد الجنود والاسلحه والدبابات في هذه
المنطقه خلال نهايه السنه المنفقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه افغانيات يروينا
للعربيه كيف قتلت انظمه الحاكمه دور
المراه وحولتها ورقه سياسيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد ابدا التل ابيب تمسكها
بثوابتها العسكريه ازاء التهديد النوويه
الايرانيه فقد اكد وزير الخارجيه اسرائيل
الجديد لكوهين في كلمته الاولى بعد السلام
مهامه التزام بلاده بمنع ايران من الحصول
على قدرات نوويه عسكريه وتطوير القدرات
العسكريه والعمل على جبهه دوليه مشتركه
لمواجهه التهديدات الايرانيه
يمدينات اسرائيل ملتزمه بمنع ايران من
الحصول على قدره النوويه عسكريه باي وسيله
على خلفيه الاجماع الدوليه على ان الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لم يعد جدول سنركز على
جانب تعزيز القدرات الامنيه المستقله لاي
سيناريو في محاوله لتشكيل جبهه دوليه لمنع
البرنامج النووي الايراني ان تصرفات ايران
لا تنعكس فقط في طموحها لامتلاك اسلحه
النوويه بل تنعكس ايضا في مشروع الصواريخ
بعيده المدام مثل الطائرات بدون طيار
وتمويل الارهاب الدولي ويجيبوا على دول
العالم ان تتوقف عن دفن رؤوسها في الرمال
ولا تخفي دوائر استراتيجيه واهميه قلقها
من امكانيه ان تشهد العلاقه مع البيت
الابيض توترات على خلفيه هيمنه وزراء
متطرفين على اجنده حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
وان يقود في حال انفجار الوضع مع
الفلسطينيين الى زعزعه الدعم الامريكي لتل
ابيب حتى فيما يتعلق بمواجهه الملف
الايراني
لا تغير ينتظر في سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بخصوص استمرار
الغارات على ما تسميه اسرائيل التموضع
الايراني في سوريا او مواجهه المشروع
النووي
الايرانيات سود دوائر امنيه واستراتيجيه
اسرائيليه من ان يقود وجود متطرفين في
الحكومه الى اشعال مواجهه مع الفلسطينيين
ما قد يؤثر على العلاقه مع الاداره
الامريكيه الديمقراطيه حتى في التعاون على
مواجهه ايران
متناقضان يمكنهما تسريع لعمليه التي
تحدثنا عنها والتي نحذر منها عمليه تهديد
الدعم الامريكي الاوتوماتيكي لاسرائيل على
المدى الطويل واحتمال المسي بالعلاقات
الخاصه مع الامريكيين وفي الخلفيه
انتقادات الديمقراطيين لنتنياهو
ورغم ان اسرائيل اجرد مناورات فرديه واخرى
مشتركه مع الامريكيين ودول اخرى حاكه
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه الى ان
القدره العسكريه علشان هجوم اسرائيليا
منفرد لم تكتمل بعد معضله اسرائيل ان
استراتيجيتها باتت عالقه منعت الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لكن بدون وجود خطه دوليه
او حتى اسرائيليه جاهزه بينما تهرب ودود
طهران نحو القنبله النوويه تخصيبا
لليورانيوم
الجمهوريه بين الاداره الامريكيه وايه
اسرائيل في نظاره الى الملف الايراني والى
طريقه التعامل مع هذا التهديد علاقه
نتنياه الفاتره باداره بيد وتشكيكه فيها
بتاكيده مؤخرا فقط بانه لن يشاركها امر
الضربه لا خشيه من تسريب الامر لمنعها قد
يترك اسرائيل وحدها في المواجهه الى حد
كبير ثم ادراك استراتيجيه في اسرائيل بان
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه يحتاج
دعما وتسليح نوعيا امريكيه لتنفيذه بنجاح
والا فان التلويح بالضرب يصبح تلويحا
بمسدس فارغ من الطلقات زياد حلب العربيه
القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار حمله القمع التي يمارسها
النظام الايراني ضد المحتاجين وما يرافقها
من اعتقالات واعدامات ايضا طلبت منظمه
العفو الدوليه ايران بوقف فوري لحكم
الاعلام الصادر بحق المتظاهر الشاب محمد
دبراني والغاء العقوبه الصادره بحقه
المنظمه دانت ايضا قرار المحكمه العليا
بايران الصدر ضد برغني على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات ووصفه محاكمته امام القضاء
بالصوريه
هناك طمع ايرانيون اخر انه القمع الرقمي
للسلطات الايرانيه للمحتاجين وحجم وسائل
التواصل الذي يضعوا البلاد في لوائح
التصنيفات السلبيه اخر هذه التصنيفات
احصائيه لشركه الامن كلاود فلير
الالكترونيه التي وضعت ايران على راسي
قائمه البلدان التي تشهد مرورا ضارا على
شبكه الانترنت
وتعني حركه المرور الضاره التطبيقات
الخبيثه التي تقوم بزراعه المواقع بغيه
تخريبها والتشويش عليها وحجمها بالاضافه
الى التجسس وترى كلود فلير حاليا ان اكثر
من 83% من حركه الانترنت في ايران من
النوع الدار ويتم عبر روبوتات او حركه
مرور الاليه تزحف الى الويب وتجمع
البيانات منه
[موسيقى]
قال المرصد السوريه والحقوق الانسان الى
70 عنصر من فيصل من فصيل الفاطميون
الافغانيه الموالي لايران تلقوا تدريبات
على استخدام الطائرات المسيره في محافظه
دير الزور مضيفا ان 26 عصرا من
المتدربين تم ارسالهم لايران من اجل
الخضوع لتدريبات العسكريه المكثفه في مجال
الاستخبارات
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا لكن في ملف اخر لا يزال اللقاء
الاخير بين وزراء الدفاع التركيه والسوري
والروسي يصنع الحدث في الداخل السريسي ما
لدى المعارضه وبينما اصوات المعرض السوريه
رفضها للتقارب التركي السوريه
المعارض بطلب عقد اجتماع عاجل مع مسؤوليه
الحكومه في التركيه رغم رفض هذا التقرب
الا ان المعارضه السوريه لم توجه اي
انتقادات مباشره لانقره وطالبتها فقط
بتوضيحات حوله هذا اللقاء
والنقطه التي استاثرت بالاهتمام الاكبر في
اعقاب هذا الاجتماع اكيد وسائل الاعلام من
تابعه للنظام السوري على موافقه تركيا
انسحاب جيشها بالكامل من الشمال السوري
انقره لم تؤكد الخبر بشكل صريح حيث اكتفى
وزير الخارجيتها من تشاو شغله بابداء
استعداد بلاده تسليم المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرتها للنظام حاله تحقق الاستقرار
السياسي
وفي خبر اخر في تركيا ايضا نقل مسؤول كبير
في حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم الى الحزم
الذي يتزحمه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يفكر
في اجراء تغيير في موعد الانتخابات
المقرره في منتصف يونيو حزيران المقبل
وردنا على سؤال بخصوص امكانيه اجراء
انتخابات مبكرا قال للمتحدث باسم الحزب
انه يتم بحث عمليه تقديم موعد الانتخابات
المقررات في الثامن عشر من يونيو بسبب
تزامنه مع موسم العطله الصيفيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهده العاصمه التونسيه وبعض المدن
اضرابا واسعا لسائقي سيارات الاجره
احتجاجا على تدني الاجور وظروف العمل
الصعبه الاضراب خلف شلالا في حركه التنقل
واضطراب في شبكات النقل عبر الحفلات
والسكك الحديديه ايضا
في محطه الجمهوريه بتونس العاصمه وجد كمال
نفسه
حيث زوجته المريضه بانتظاره امل كمال
الحافلات ولا المتر الخفيف يشتغل بسبب
اضراب عمال شركه نقل تونس
المتزامن مع اضراب سائق التكسير الفرديه
النقل
التونسيين تقطعت بهم السبل البعض يلهث
وراء وسيله نقل الخاصه وخير البعض الذهاب
الى العمل او دراسه مشيا على الاقدام وسط
حاله من الغضب والاحتقال
ما احد شيء صدقني شيء اسف وشي حزن وليدي
هنا واحده من
الناسكم في المروج هفضل تونس همت منكم حتى
على بعضهم
واللي جاي من المرسى يمشي يمشي يمكن
عمال
الى ساحه الحكومه بالقصبه وهناك بوقفه
احتجاجيه للمطالبه بصرف اجورهم وتحسين
الماليه
الاكله المتخلفه لمده شهرين
التي تواجهها الشركات العامه
[موسيقى]
وليد عبد الله العربيه تونس
في اوروبا ايضا تلوح في الافق مؤشرات
الطاقه التي ضربت القاره
عاشتها العديد من البلدان الاوروبيه على
خلفيه ايقاف امدادات الغاز الروسيه
الغاز المسال ستزداد خلالها هذا العام فمن
المتوقع ان ترتفع قدره الاستراد بنسبه 20%
بحلول ديسمبر المقبل وذلك وفقه معلومات
رصدتها منصه
ميديا المختصه في الطاقه هذا ونجحت اوروبا
في تنويع مصادر امداداتها من الغاز كما تم
التخطيط لبناء محطات استيراد جديده
ويبدو ان ازمه الغاز تجاوزت مراحلها
الصعبه حيث انخفض سعر الجمله للغاز
الطبيعي في اوروبا بنور 50% في غضون شهر
واحد وهو ادنى مستوى له منذ بدايه الحرب
في اوكرانيا ويرجع سبب هذا لانخفاض الى
دفء فصل الشتاء نسبيا في اوروبا هذه السنه
ما سمح بتوفير المخزون
[موسيقى]
والى جانبه ازمه الطاقه التي اثرت على كل
دول العالم الركود والتضخم يعبثان
بالاقتصاد العالمي ويدفعان دول عديده الى
اتخاذ قرارات صعبه من بين هذه هي الدول
بريطانيا التي تعيش ازمه تضخم من حقيقيه
دفعتها الى تبني سياسه التقشف فالمملكه
المتحده سجلت نسبه تضخم القياسيه خلال سنه
الماضيه تتجاوزت للعشره في المئه وهي
الاعلى منذ اربعه عقود كما ارتفعت اسعار
المواد الغذائيه بمعدل وصل الى احد 10%
كلها عوامل ادت الى انخفاض قيمه الاجور
وتدني مستوى المعيشه ما اسفر عن موجه
احتجاجات واضرابات غير مسبوقه اجتاحت
البلاد خلال شهر ديسمبر
الحكومه البريطانيه رات اذا في سياسه
التقشف فوق نجاه لمواجهه هذه الازمه
المرشحه الى الاستمرار خلال هذه السنه
الجديده الحكومه قررت خفض الانفاق بما
يعادل 55 مليار جنيه استرليني في السنه
كما اقررت ضرائب استثنائيه من بينها ضريبه
على ارباح شركه الطاقه تصل الى 35 بالمئه
وتمتد حتى العام 2018 كما فرضت ضريبه
قاسيه على منتجين الكهرباء نسبتها 45%
لكن من بين القرارات المثيره للجدل التي
اتخذتها الحكومه البريطانيه تقليص الدعم
الموجه لقطاعات الفنون والثقافه من 36
مليون جنيه استرليني الى 19 مليون على ان
تحول قيمته تلك التخفيضات لدعم العلوم
الاساسيه والتكنولوجيا والهندسه
[موسيقى]
وتابع من لندن مع عروب عبد الحق مراسله
العربيه عروب اهلا بك معنا كيف يتفاعل
البريطانيون وكيف يتاقلمون كذلك مع سياسه
التقشف هذه من قبل الحكومه البريطانيه
الحكومه البريطانيه التي نحن الان في
مقرها هنا في تن داونز ستريت والتي لم
يمضي على تواليها قياده ااه القياده
الحكومه ثلاثه اشهر بانها قادره على
المحافظه على مستوى المعيشه للمواطن
البريطاني والمقيم ولكن ممكن ان نقول بان
البريطاني ونودعوا عام 2022 بسعاده همم
رغم ان عام 2023 لا ينبض بانه سيكون افضل
حالا من عمل 2022 حتى رئيس الوزراء ريشه
هناك في رسالته لنهايه العام قال بان على
البريطانيين الاستعداد لسنه صعبه همم بسبب
بقى الاوضاع الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها
البلاد وبالتالي يمكن رصد ردود فعل
البريطانيين بشكل عام من خلال الاضطرابات
التي رايناها همم في قطاعات مختلفه في
بريطانيا سواء في النقل وفي الصحه حتى
الاسعاف والممرضين الذين يعني همم اضربوا
لاول
النقابات البريطانيه لن تتوقف عند هذا
الحد هناك يعني سلسله من الاضرابات منتظره
كذلك خلال 2023
بدات النقابات
الاعلامي الاضرابات في يناير وفي الاشهر
القليله المقبله اذا لم اا يعني اا تحقق
الحكومه مطالبهم برفع الاجور بمستوى
يعني يتناسب او يتناسب مع معدل التضخم
الحاصل في البلاد وبالتالي نعم ننتظر لنرى
كيف ستكون هذه همم الاضرابات وكيف سيحل
همم ريش السوناتا هذه الازمه التي من
المتوقع ان تكون اكبر تحدياتها في عام
2023 والتي كما نرى بدات ايضا هذه
السياسات التقشف التي طبعا تتماشى مع
الخطه الاقتصاديه والميزانيه التي تم
الاعلان عنها في نوفمبر العام الماضي كيف
ستؤثر على قطاعات مختلفه ومنها كما ذكرت
مصادر قوه الناعمه هنا في بريطانيا
عروبه عبد الحق مراسله عربيه مباشره من 10
دوله مقر الحكومه البريطانيه في لندن شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وصفه معاناه النساء في افغانستان بعد قيود
طالبان بمنعهن من العمل والتعليم روى
الطالبات افغانيات للعربيه كيف تحكمت
الانظمه على مدى العقود الاربع الماضيه في
المراه
وسلبتهن حقوقهن وحولت قضاياهن الى ورقه
سياسيه بيد الجماعات من اجل السلطه
صالح تخرجت من جامعه كابول قبل 35 عاما في
عهد الرئيس الاسبق نجيب الله تقول انها
وزميلاتها كنا يدرسن في فصول مشتركه مع
الفتيان في وقت كانت الحريه تسود الاجواء
التعليميه ان ذلك وخاصه زي الفتيات
اكرامي
كما كانت المراه تستطيع ان تختار تخصصها
في جميع المجالات المتاحه دون ان يدعوائق
اما شقيقه صالحه فقد التحقت بجامعه كابول
بعد عامين من صالحه ولكنها لم تستطع
مواصله الدراسه جراء ظروف عسكريه تضيف ان
المراه الافغانيه قد ظلمت قديما وحديثا
بدرجات مختلفه
الاجتماعيه
فقد تم القضاء على عمليه دراستهن وتدريسهن
في البلد
التي تخرجت منها صالح اكبر واشهر جامعه في
افغانستان والتي تم تاسيسها سنه
1930 ميلاديه قدمت الالاف من الخريجات في
تخصصات مختلفه الى المجتمع الافغاني
المسيره الطويله في رحله تعليم الفتيات لن
تتوقفها فالمجتمع للافغاني وعلى الرغم من
الازمات المتلاحقه تظل رغبه الافغان
بمستقبل افضل يكون فيه التعليمه حجر
الزاويه عبد القادر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه رونالدو يصل
الرياض ويستعد لحفل ضخم في مرسول مبارك
غدا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد التقى رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان
رئيس المخابرات العامه المصريه اللواء
عباس كامل الذي نقل رساله شفويه من الرئيس
المصري تتعلق بالعلاقات الثنائيه وسبل
دعمها وتطويرها كما كان رئيس المجلس
الانتقالي على اهميه العلاقات السودانيه
المصريه
وضروره تعزيزها بما يخدم المصالح المشتركه
[موسيقى]
صوت المجلس الاعلى لدوله الليبيه
بالموافقه على استئناف الحوار مع مجلس
النواب كما صوت المجلس على رفض دعوه
المجلس الرئاسي للاجتماعي في غدامس والذي
كان مقررا في 11 من يناير الجاري بحضور
رئيس مجلس النواب علي صالح
[موسيقى]
انضمت قطر الى الدول التي وضعت قيود السفر
واعلنت فرضه تقديم نتيجه سلبيه لاختبار
كورونا على جميع المسافرين القادرين من
الصين اعتبارا من الغد وذكرته وكاله
الانباء الرسميه ان الشرطه الاختبار
المفروض على جميع المسافرين بغض النظر عن
التطعيم كما اعلن المغرب حضره دخول جميع
القادمين من الصين بغض النظر عن الجنسيهم
[موسيقى]
يوم رياضي استثنائيه ستعيشه العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض يوم الثلاثاء فالامطار
ستتجه الى ملعب مرسول مبارك الذي سيحتضن
حفله تقديم النجم البرتغاليه كريستيانو
رونالدو المنظم حديثا لنادي النصر السعودي
الذي وصل الى قبل قليل الى العاصمه
السعوديه من المتوقع ان يعرف حفل تقديم
النجم البرتغالي حضورا جماهيريا غفيرا حيث
نفذ الجميع
المخصصه للحدث وكان النصر قد تعاقد مع
رونالدو في صفقه بلغت قيمتها حوالي 200
مليون يورو سيحمل بموجبها اللاعب قميص
نادي النصر لمده موسمين
المقاس لقيته خلال يعني خمس دقائق عشر
دقائق
بخصوص الطباعه قال لي بعد ثلاث ايام وانت
عارف الحفله بكره فاضطريت اني اشوف اي محل
ثاني اني اطبع يعطيك الرقم والاسم واطلع
برا ما شاء الله هنا بالنسبه
رونالدو قبل رونالدو مع النصر يعني بس ما
شاء الله هنا سواء الابلكيشن او حتى في
المتجر نفسه الخدمه ما شاء الله يعني
سريعه وكل شيء متوفر يعني موجود حاليا
حتى انا طلبت الاسم لكن قالوا بعد ثلاث
ايام
[موسيقى]
القاء عشرات الاف المسافرين في المطارات
الفلبينيه بعدما تسبب انقطاع في التيار
الكهربائي بانقطاع الاتصالات في مانيلا
وادى الى الغاء 100 رحلات او تاخيرها او
تحويل مسارها وجرى الغاءه او تحويله او
تاخير اكثر من 360 رحله جويه داخل مانيلا
وخارجها ما اثر على خطط سفر نحوي
56000 مسافر
[موسيقى]
اسطنبول
ده ده البودن
بده
الناس
[موسيقى]
اه اه
العناوين الساعه
تفوق اوكرانيا في الحرب الالكترونيه ويفضح
اخطاء روسيا المتكرره والفادحه
من توتر العلاقه مع واشنطن واسرائيل تجهز
قدراتها لتحرك مستقل ضد اي سيناريو نووي
الايراني بعد القمر الرقمي ايران على راس
الدولي التي تشهد تطبيقات خبيثه لتشويش
وحجم الانترنت والتجسس
واستا ركود يهدد العالم وسياسه تقشف قاسيه
في بريطانيا اسعار الغاز تنقذ اوروبا من
ازمه ثقه
شكرا على المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]